news that a covid vaccine is close has
felt like christmas come early after
months of restrictions
but delivering the doses to everyone in
the country will be a logistical
nightmare
today nadim zahawi was given the job of
overseeing the rollout calling on the
army if necessary to make it happen
the prime minister made it very clear
that i've got the the ability to use
the army and army personnel who are
brilliant
at logistical challenges and i will be
certainly
making sure that i use everything that's
available to me to deliver on this uh
enormous challenge that we have to
deliver on
but the scale of the challenge ahead is
huge this is going to be the logistical
challenge
probably of this century it's not just
about the vaccine
it's also about all the things you need
to do the
final vaccination that includes personal
protective equipment
includes the syringes it includes the
needles
and it has to be a success boris johnson
knows that without a vaccine he'll need
to impose strict rules to stop the virus
spreading
like the tough new tier system which has
drawn criticism from his own mps
including mr zahawi to head off a
potential rebellion in the house of
commons boris johnson isn't just
unveiling a new minister he's also set
out a series of concessions in a letter
to conservative mps
he hopes the promise of more data a
strict time limit on tough new tears and
a road map to move from tier 3 to tier 1
will be enough to convince his mps
if it isn't he may have to rely on
labour to get the legislation passed in
the vote next tuesday
two of the most significant failures
during this pandemic that have really
held us back
have been the the problems we've had
over getting ppe to the front line
and the ongoing problems we've got uh
with the test and trace system
and i think in both cases a lack of
ministerial oversight's been a real
problem
and even then the public are getting fed
up too i own a coffee shop
it's terminal for us really i don't
understand why they've taken us
out of postcode and put us into county
you could keep on you know dissecting
and cutting it up as much as you want
but i think at some point you've got to
draw a line and
i think everybody seems to uh i think
there's a will amongst people that
you know let's just get through this
none of it's fair is it we're in a
pandemic
viruses aren't fair either things may be
looking brighter than they have for
months but there's still
a long way to go